get out of the way
excuse me can you name fruit they want
to speak to me
cannot be a woman a man cannot conceive
he has a penis
Ali no more than you it's budget time
now bro have no choice
is it
brothers and sisters don't worry it's
just a few coloring but if he woke me up
for one Salah he will get the reward
from my entire Salah too but we can't
wake up people for Fajr every day around
the world but what you can do is help us
teach thousands of reverts and thousands
of Muslims who never learn how to pray
but if you're the one who gave the
hard-earned money to just sponsor one
Salama then every time that person
performs Salah you sharing the rewards
just a hundred pounds can teach up to 10
people how to pray Salah plant the sea
today by clicking the button or the link
and donating now
[Music]
why are you guys afraid to talk
if a child cannot drink alcohol at the
age of 18 why do they do how could they
decide the agenda
if we say a child cannot watch
pornography or drink alcohol at the age
of 18. how could they decide the agenda
I thought so there's nothing there's
nothing much can be said
a child Conjuring alcohol to the age of
18 can't watch pornography at the age of
16 how does a child decide the agenda uh
three years old or four years old or
five years old
why don't you talk how is that going to
help you effort how's that going to help
you
[Applause]
so do you think they can decide the
agenda at the age of three or four years
old and they can get puberty blockers
I mean if I was you I would come on my
face if I was you I would use a big
umbrella I don't blame you so as you can
see guys we're trying to win a civilized
dialogue I mean I'm the one fast in here
yeah I'm the one who's fasting but it
seems like they don't want to talk about
sisters I've got the energy they don't
have the energy I'm just asking a simple
question a very simple question a child
cannot drink alcohol until they're 18
years old
a child is told to stay away no one's
pornography until you're 16 or 18. not
do drugs but then they are the same
people who are telling us that a child
can decide their gender and use puberty
blockers to which so we're just trying
to have a dialogue with them and talk to
them and make me understand convince me
how a child at the age of three four
five or six do you believe a child at
the age of four years old can decide the
agenda
why why are you guys afraid to talk why
don't you convince me maybe I'll join
you
promised me Madam
a child cannot watch pornography to the
age of 16 to 18. I believe they
shouldn't worship period they can't
drink alcohol unless they're 18 years
old there you go listen
don't pass me I'm not feminist yeah
don't budge me don't try those budgets
on me yeah you can deal with the
feminist don't try that with me yeah
okay I'm not feminist or lesbian don't
try barging me look look
pregnant
can you become pregnant I'm asking a
question as a man can you become
pregnant if you can't that's a
scientific fact you cannot
the feminist lesbians you know because
we agree on something with them at least
[Music]
they just saying that a biological man
cannot be a woman a man cannot conceive
he has a penis it's a fact it's a fact
do you believe you can conceive sir
do you believe you can conceive
where's the feminist
we need to join the feminists
where's the feminist I need to join them
I never thought the time would come
I never thought I would join the
feminists
umbrella oh my gosh
umbrella
hey guys
remember
[Applause]
leave that in the way move out of the
way move out of the way move out of the
way
get my camera
he's with me he's with me
excuse me mother mother mother
this with me they agreed to live with me
yes
[Music]
you can see guys the the families here
had no choice but to leave these guys
are violent folks yeah you've never seen
this this side of the to the lgbqt these
guys are violent thugs they've been
pushing our cameraman they've been
getting violent these guys are absolute
[__] these are radicals they're like
extremist radicals yeah all we want to
do is have an intellectual discussion
the feminists have no choice but to for
their own safety to leave and they are
just stating a biological bloody fact
it's a scientific fact that a man cannot
conceive and that a man who identifies
this is unbelievable I can't believe
we're actually having a discussion on
this matter stay away from our kids stay
away from our kids stay away from our
kids today guys was in historical moment
in Speakers Corner I never thought would
join the feminists against these radical
extremists LGBT movements yeah today the
Christians the Muslims the Jews the
atheists the agnostics you name it we're
all on the One Roof against these
radical Maniacs who are trying to
comfort our kids yes so today we expose
them as they mean violent Thugs who are
against freedom of speech I mean myself
I'm against certain parts of being
displeased they are totally against them
they do not want to talk to us neither
do they want us to talk and we expose
these cowards and this is the true face
of the lgbqt this is what they're about
they cannot talk intellectually that the
lgbtqt have become a religion they're
not they're not a movement they are
religion literally and it seems like
they're a very vital religion yeah the
fact the way they treat it I'm not
feminist I'm speaking of spoken against
feminism but on this matter with the
feminists I'm on their side why because
they're speaking mere facts scientific
biological facts and just because of
that these people have been so radical
they've been attacking our cameramen
they've been pushing shoveling sticking
their
umbrellas in our faces why because we
want to have an intellectual discussion
none of them wanted to talk and I think
they've got nothing to speak about just
like Jeffrey Marsh and him trying to
poison the minds of our kids I ask a
simple question
a child we tell a child you cannot drink
alcohol until you're 18. yeah if they
try to go to these adult pages they will
ask you to verify your age
when it comes to taking drugs there is
an age limit when it comes to
a a a teenager whatever it may be to
have intimacy there's a set age but to
the LGBT radicals extremists they are
saying that a child at the age of three
or four can turn around and say I'm a
woman
I mean this is to me Preposterous and I
wanted to have an international
discussion but they are literally
violent thugs this is the true face of
lgbtqt they are violent Fox after what
they did to the hijabi sister he was
calling out Jeffrey marshmallow yeah
bloody trying to poison our kids Minds
we are seeing the reality of the lgbqt
do do not be surprised that if a day
comes these individuals would go to the
levels of take harming people physically
literally to the extent of maybe
murdering them for their views that's
what we saw today and thank you to
lgbtqt community for showing us your
true face today with all your followers
you guys are violent Thug extremist
radicals that's all I have to say
inshallah